[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من السودان وهذه
الصور التي نتابعها مباشره من الخرطوم حيث
توسعت الاشتباكات تزامنا مع اكمال المعارك
شهرها الثاني
وهذه الصور من بيروت التي تعيش على وقع
انقسام سياسيا حاد مع اخفاق البرلمان
للمره الثانيه عشره في انتخاب رئيس للبلاد
ومن اسطنبول في تركيا تردنا هذه الصور بعد
عقد اجتماع الرابع في انقره للاليه
المشتركه الدائمه بمشاركه مسؤولين من
تركيا والسويد وفنلندا والذي تم خلاله
الاتفاق على مواصله العمل بشان خطوات
انضمام السويد للحلف
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
شهر ثاني من المعاركي يكتمل في السودان
توسع في الاشتباكات
والجيش يغير لاول مره على مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع في شمال كردفان ويقول انه
تصدى لهجوم هو الاول بالمسيرات على سلاح
المدرعات في الخرطوم واستمرار المعارك في
دارفور يدفع بمزيد من اللاجئين الى مدينه
في لبنان اخفاق للمره الثانيه عشره في
انتخاب رئيس للبلاد داخل البرلمان جهه
ازعور يدعو الاحترام راي اغلبيه النواب
ومنافسه سليمان فرنجيه يدعو لحوار بناء
لتحقيق المصلحه الوطنيه
تدعو القاده اللبنانيين الى تجاوز ما
وصفته بالشلل السياسي
على وقع ضربات صاروخيه متبادله في
اوكرانيا كيف تعلن سقوط قتلى في قصف روسيا
على اوديسا وموسكو تؤكد التصدي لهجمات
اوكرانيه على ثلاث جبهات
والمانيا تعلن لاول مره استراتيجيه للامن
القومي تعتبر روسيا اكبر تهديد لاوروبا
والنيتو
القياده الوسطى الامريكيه تعلن نشر طائرات
اف 22 رابتر في الشرق الاوسط في ضوء ما
وصفته بالسلوك غير الامن لطائرات روسيا
وقائد القوات الجويه الامريكيه في الشرق
الاوسط يقول للجزيره ان الطيران الروسي
يناور بشكل عدوانيا في سوريا ولا يلتزم
بالبروتوكولات
وفي لقاءنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اخفاق البرلمان اللبناني
للمره الثانيه عشره في انتخاب رئيسا
للبلاد بسبب تعذر حصول اي من المرشحين على
ثلثي الاصوات استطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم ما الاحتمال الاقرب في مساله
انتخاب رئيس لبناني ثلاثه عشر في المئه
صوت لصالح فوز جهاد ازعور بينما صوت
22% لصالح فوز سليمان فرنجيه اما 65%
فراوا ان المشهد متجه نحو استمرار تعذر
الحسم هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا بالجراد تقول
انها اعتقلت ثلاثه افراد من شرطه كوسوفو
دخلوا اراضيها مسلحين رشينا تقول ان
الصرمه اختطفوا ضباط الثلاثه ورئيسه
كوسوفو تدعو المجتمع الدولي الى مواجهه ما
وصفته بمحاولات صربيا زعزعه استقرار
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
البدايه من السودان وانقضاء شهرين كاملين
منذ بدء المعارك بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع ففي الخرطوم تواصلت المعارك
بالاسلحه في مناطق عده وافاد مصر طبي
بوقوع عدد من القتلى والجرحى جراء قصف
استهدف منطقه حي النهضه بضاحيه الانقاذ
جنوب الخرطوم وفي ام درمان شرق الخرطوم بث
ناشطون صورا اظهرت دمارا في منطقه مجمع
المحاكم بشارع الوادي اثر قصفا جوي
وفي تطور غير مسبوقه قال مصر وانا عسكري
ومطلع في الجيش السوداني للجزيره ان قوات
الجيش تمكنت من اسقاط مسيرتين اثناء
محاوله قوات الدعم السريع امس قصف سلاح
المدرعات بالخرطوم بينما نقلت وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه عن مسؤول عسكريا قوله ان
استخدام قوات الدعم السريع مسيرات في
هجومها يثير شكوكا بشان مصدرها في المقابل
قال مصدر من قوات الدعم السريع للوكاله
انه تم الحصول على المسيرات من مراكز
للجيش سيطرت عليها قواته
كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بان الجيش
السوداني قصف بالطائرات للمره الاولى
مواقع لتمركز قوات الدعم السريع في مدينه
الاوبيض عاصمه ولايه شمال كردفان وسط
السودان واضاف مراسلنا ان قوات الدعم
السريع ردت باطلاق مضادات الطيران
اما في غرب البلاد فافاد مراسلنا على
الحدود السودانيه تشاديه بسماع يدوي
القذائف الثقيله على مدار الساعات الماضيه
في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غربي دارفور
السودانيه ومحيطها واضاف مراسلنا ان
المعارك بين المسلحين القبليين مستمره ما
يدفع كثيرين للفرار الى ادري في تشاد ونقل
مراسلنا عنشود عياننا الجنينه تعاني من
نقص حاد في مياه الشرب والمواد الغذائيه
وان معظم السكان غير قادرين على الفرار
منها
اذا شهراني من المعارك في السودان خلف
ازمه سياسيه في البلاد ولم يحسم القتال
ولا الوسطاء امر هذه الازمه حتى الان
لم يبقى السودان كما كان قبل شهرين استيقظ
السودانيون يوم الخامس عشر من ابريل على
اشتباكات غير مسبوقه في مكانها واطرافها
يقود المعارك رئيس مجلس السياده قائد
الجيش في مقابل قائد الدعم السريع الذي
كان نائبا للبرهان في مجلس السياده
روايتان لتطور الاحداث بدات الشراره من
مروي شمال العاصمه حينما حاصرت قوه الدعم
السريع القاعده العسكريه هناك اذ قال
الجيش حينها ان الدعم السريع حاول السيطره
على القاعده بينما قال الدعم السريع ان
قوات من الجيش هاجمته في محيط القصر
الجمهوري بالعاصمه الخرطوم
انتقلت شراره المعارك من وسط الخرطوم
ومروي لتشمل كل البلاد خلال الايام الاولى
من القتال بين كر وفر تركزت الاشتباكات
مؤخرا في الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث والمناطق
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من البلاد
يتنازع الطرفان السيطره على المراكز
الحساسه القصر الجمهوري والوزارات
السياديه بجواره مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه لذلك مقر يلاصق مطار
الخرطوم الذي خرج عن الخدمه خلال الساعات
الاولى من هذه المعارك بسط الجيش مؤخرا
سيطرته على المقاطع الرئيسيه من العاصمه
ويقول انه يلاحق مجموعات الدعم السريع في
الاحياء تتصاعد ارقام الضحايا تحصي نقابه
اطباء السودان مقتل اكثر من 960 شخصا
واصابه اربعه الاف وثمانمائه والارقام
بطبيعه الحال حتى ساعه اعداد هذا التقرير
ولا تشمل ما يجري غرب دارفور وتحديدا
الجنينه التي يشهد معارك متواصله منذ
اسابيع يزيد من سوءها تداخل الاطراف
القبليه في الصراع القتلى والمصابون ليسوا
وحدهم ضحايا القتال غادر اكثر من مليون
و600 الف سوداني منازلهم الى مدن اخرى
داخل البلاد بينما غادر اكثر من 470 الفا
الحدود الى دول مجاوره بينهم مئه الف من
غير السودانيين عادوا الى بلادهم الى
التفرع منها الى السودان قبل هذه الازمه
بعد ايام من اندلاع المعارك بدات الوساطات
الخارجيه بحثا عن حل قدمت منظمه لايجاد
مباادره لوقف القتال تضمنت افاده ممثلين
عن طرفي الصراع الى عاصمه جنوب السودان
للتفاوض حول تفاصيل المبادره بعد ايام قدم
الاتحاد الافريقي كذلك خريطه طريق للحل
تضمنت وقفا فوريا ودائما لاطلاق النار
واستكمال العمليه السياسيه الانتقاليه لكن
الوساطه الاهم كانت الوساطه السعوديه
الامريكيه تلك وساطه استطاعت جمع الطرفين
في مدينه جده السعوديه واجراء مباحثات غير
مباشره اسفرت عن عده هدى صحيح انها هدن
قصيره ولم تصمت كثيرا لكن هذه الوساطه
كانت الاكثر تاثيرا
هكذا يدخل القتال في السودان شهره الثالث
قتال لم تحسمه البنادق فلا تحركات دروس
طاقه
[موسيقى]
للمزيد ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الدكتور
اسامه عيدروس الاكاديميه السودانيه المختص
في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه دكتور مرحبا
بك معنا
مع يعني انتهاء الشهرين ودخول المعارك هذا
الشهر الثالث
هل استراتيجيه الحسم العسكري هي النهج
المتبع لكلا الطرفين
وبصوره مؤكده دون التعويل على
نهج اخر
الواقع انا نفسي اتساءل
قوات الدعم السريع بعد بدايه الحرب مباشره
ويعني خساره الهدف السياسي للحرب من
السيطره على السلطه في الخرطوم وفي في
السودان يعني لماذا تستمر في الحرب كل هذه
الفتره
بدلا من ان تخسر المعركه الاولى وتستمر في
التحضير لحرب مستقبليه يعني كان بامكانها
بمجرد ما فشل هجومها الاول على القياده
العامه
وطارت اول طائره سوخوي من القاعده الجويه
يعني اتضح انه هذا الانقلاب قد فشل كان
يمكن لها بعد ذلك خصوصا مع وجود وساطات
نادت بهدى كثيره جدا ان تتوقف عن الحرب
لكن هي استمرت في حرب نزيف لقواتها بشكل
يعني مستمر حاولت في البدايه ان
تهاجم في كل انحاء السودان فشلت في ذلك حا
ان تسيطر على الخرطوم خصوصا انها متحكمه
في الاماكن الاستراتيجيه الموجوده في
الخرطوم فشلت في ذلك بعض يعني فشل هجوم
القياده والطيران وضرب معسكراتها يعني
انتشرت في الخرطوم انتشار واسع وكانها قد
استولت على الخرطوم اتضح ان هذه
استراتيجيه خاسره عرضتها للكثير من
الاستنزاف على طول هذا الوقت نزيف في
الافراد نزيف في العربات
وفقدت كل رصيدها السياسي مع عمليات تدمير
هائله للمرافق والبنى التحتيه احتلال
المستشفيات ترويع المواطنين احتلال بيوتهم
اخراجهم من بيوتهم بالقوه فقدت كل رصيدها
السياسي كحركه يعني تتحدث عن تحول
ديموقراطي وتتحدث عن مثل ذلك ولكن السيطره
العسكريه لم تحسم حتى الان لصالح الجيش
ولا زالت قوات الدعم السريع تستطيع
السيطره وتستطيع الانتشار في مساحات داخل
الخرطوم ليست الهينه وايضا تستطيع ان توسع
القتال الى اماكن اخرى خارج الخرطوم الحسم
العسكري هل لا زال هو ما يعول عليه
الطرفان طيب هل هي تستطيع السيطره ام
تستطيع الانتشار لانه الفرق واضح بين
المصطلحين هي ما زالت تستطيع ان تدير
معارك ما زالت تستطيع ان ان تنتشر في
الخرطوم لانها اصلا سياسه يعني عقيدتها
القتاليه هي عقيده تقوم على ما نسميه في
السودان الفزع ان يتجمع مجموعه منهم
بعربات ذات قوه نيران كثيفه ويهجم على
موقع ما لكن المعرفه تدرس من مؤشراتها
العامه المؤشرات العامه تقول انه فقدوا
الهدف السياسي ثم فقدوا الهدف العسكري
وفقدوا القياده والسيطره الان اخر هجوم تم
التنسيق له بشكل متزامن بقوات كبيره الدعم
السريع كان هجوم على القوات على وادي
سيدنا القاعده الجويه وعلى المهندسين وعلى
المدرعات فشل هذا الهجوم المتزامن لعدم
قدرتهم على حشد القوات ولعدم وجود قياده
وسيطره لهم هل نقلوا بعدها لم يستطيعوا ان
ينسقوا هجوم كبير حقيقه لهم بعض النجاحات
في الاستراتيجيه في اليرموك بعض المواقع
هنا وهناك ولكنه فقدوا القدره على
المناوره العسكريه الكبيره التي تستطيع ان
تحقق لهم شيئا وفي مع تقدم الجيش في خطته
وتحكمه في مناطق او ونقاط حاكمه في
الخرطوم فشلوا في في اسقاط اي واحده من
القيادات العسكريه وانتهى منذ زمن لم نسمع
باي هجوم لهم على القياده ولا على سلاح
الاسلحه ولا على سلاح الاشاره وحتى اليوم
سمعنا في البدايه انهم هجموا على
المهندسين واتضح ان قوات المهندسين خرجت
من عسكريها في هجوم لقوه خاصه خارج
الخرطوم هم يرتكبون الان مجازر
رهيبه في الجنينه وجرائم حرب وجرائم ضد
الانسانيه يجب ان يحاسبوا عليه
دكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني
المختص في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]
صحيح ان نتائج الجلسه الثانيه عشره
للبرلمان اللبناني لانتخاب رئيسا للبلاد
لم تختلف عن سابقاتها لكنها اظهرت انقساما
اضافيا بين مختلف الاطراف ومزيدا من
الاستعصاء السياسي
وهذا الانقسام عززه اتفاق حزبي القوات
والكتائب اللبنانيه والتيار الوطني الحر
والحزب الاشتراكي ونواب مستقلين على تاييد
جهاد ازعور مقابل تاييد حزب الله وحركه
امل ترشيح سليمان فرنجي
دوره اقتراع واحده تمت قبل فقدان النصاب
القانوني وحصد ازعور العدد الاكبر من
الاصوات يليه فرنجيه لكن ايا منهما لم
ينلي الاصوات اللازمه لانتخابه رئيسا من
الدوره الاولى وهي ثلثاء اصوات النواب اي
86 نائبا من اصل 128 صحيح انه جاد ثور جيب
اصوات كتير لكنها ليست كافيه ابدا بكل
الحالات تتعمل راي الجمهوريه ثانيا بما
يتعلق بالتامين فرنجيه كمان تبين انه من
الصعب بمكان ان يتولى الرئاسه بهكذا حجم
من الاسواق ولا يمكن اغفال التاثيرات
الخارجيه على ملف الرئاسه لا سيما مع
اعلان الرئيس الفرنسي تعيين الوزير السابق
جون ايفلود مفردا خاصا له الى لبنان يضاف
الى ذلك تلويح الاداره الامريكيه على لسان
مساعده وزير الخارجيه بامكانيه فرض عقوبات
على ساسه اللبنانيين المعرقلين للمسار
السياسي في البلاد دائما فرنسا والولايات
المتحده تتحركان بهذا بهذا الاطار هناك
دعم امريكي من خلال العقوبات وتلويح بها
من اجل دفع الافرقه المحليين الى الاتفاق
مع فرنسا وللتعاون مع فرنسا في مبادرتها
وايضا هناك محاوله فرنسيه لايجاد حلول
وسطيه
وفي الموازات تبرز دعوات الى ضروره مقاربه
ملف الرئاسه لجهات السله المتكامله التي
تشمل ايضا اليات اداره الدوله في المرحله
المقبله وكيفيه معالجه الانهيار الاقتصادي
والمالي
بعد نحو ثمانيه اشهر من الشهور الرئاسي
الى مؤشرات حتى الساعه على امكانيه انتخاب
رئيس جديد للبلاد في ظل الانقسامات
الحاصله لكن البعض يراهن على ان المعطيات
التي افرزتها جلسه الانتخاب الثانيه عشره
معطوفه على الحراك الخارجي قد تحدث دفعا
يعيد خلق الاوراق ويؤسسوا لتفاهمات جديده
جونيطانيوس الجزيره بيروت
من جانبها قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الشلل السياسي في لبنان قضيه يجب على
القاده اللبنانيين حلها وادعت الخارجيه
الامريكيه البرلمان اللبناني الى متابعه
جلسات انتخاب الرئيس خلال الايام
والاسابيع المقبله واكدت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الشعب اللبنانيه يحتاج لرئيس
يعملوا للحصول على دعم صندوق النقد الدولي
ينضم الينا من بيروت توفيق شومان الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وايضا السيد ميشال ابو
نجم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
سيد ميشيل ابو نجم هل سينتقل ما جرى من
تقاطع الضروره الذي تابعناه في الجلسه
الثانيه عشره الى الجوله المقبله في حل لم
يحدث اختراق بالنسبه لموضوع التوافق
مساء الخير لك وللاستاذ توفيق في الحقيقه
ان هذه الجلسه وكما كان متوقعا هي لم تكن
قادره على انتاج رئيس الجمهوريه لكنها
بالتاكيد احدثت خرقا في مسار الساتيكو
الذي كان قائما بالنسبه الى الجمود حول
انتخابات الرئاسه وحول تمسك الثنائي
الشيعي تحديدا
بسليمان فرنجيه اليوم باتا هناك مرشح قادر
على جمع اصوات اكبر بكثير من تلك التي كان
يحوزها المرشح ميشيل المعوض وبات هناك
بالامكان في ظل التوازنات القائمه
والحاليه التي تمنع اي طرف معين او اي قوه
سياسيه من ايصال رئيس بمفردها في اتجاه
الدفع في اتجاه حوار لبناني في اتجاه
البحث عن مخارج مختلفه
لمسار الازمه الرئاسيه الخوف كل الخوف
يعني ان ان بعض القوى قد تسكر اذا صح
التعبير على زبيبه ان المرشح سليمان
الفرنجيه هذا 51 صوتا وبالتالي القول كما
يشيع في بعض الوسائل الاعلاميه انه حاز 51
وبالتالي فريقه متماسك وبالتالي الاستمرار
في الصعود الى الشجره من دون ايجاد سلما
للنزول منها لانه كما قلت انه في ظل
التوازنات القائمه لا قدره لاي طرف على
انتاج رئيس بمفرد هناك بالتالي
توفيق شومان في ظل التوازنات القائمه اذا
كان التوافق
سيكون هو المبدا الحاسم لان هناك حاله
ستاتيكو كما يقول السيد ميشيل تحكم
العوامل في لبنان هل امكانيه انضاج هذا
التوافق لدى سياسي لبنان موجوده الان في
هذه الظروف
تحياتي اليك اولا والى الزميل الكريم يعني
طبعا لغايه الان لا لا يعني عمليه التوافق
مفقوده وبالتالي عناصر التفاهم بين القوى
السياسيه اللبنانيه مفقوده لذلك جاءت
الجلسه النيابيه اليوم لتؤكد هذا الانقسام
وتؤكد من جهه اخرى على ضروره ذهاب الاطراف
السياسيه اللبنانيه الى حوار مفقود لكن
اظن انه بعد هذه الجلسه التي لا منتصر
فيها والخاسر الوحيد هو لبنان واللبنانيون
هناك ربما نقطه ضوء قد تبرز يوم الاثنين
المقبل من خلال زياره المفرد الفرنسي الى
لبنان وزير الخارجيه السابق جون ايفلوم
واظن بانه يحمل على الاقل يعني مشروع
مبادره جديده وهو سوف يمكث في لبنان من
يوم الاثنين المقبل الى يوم الجمعه يعني
وهذه مده طويله او فتره زمنيه طويله ومن
المفترض ايضا ان يتواصل مع مختلف الاطراف
السياسيه اللبنانيه
بصوره عامه جلسه اليوم اكدت بانه لا يمكن
ان يفرد شخص او مرشح على مرشح ولا يمكن
اسقاط مرشح اخر ايضا يعني كان الهدف اليوم
هو اطاحت سليمان فرنجيه من المشهد لم يحدث
مثل هذا الامر ولكن يبقى السؤال الكبير
الى اي حد يبقى المرشح جهد ازعور يحصل على
نفس حجم الاصوات الذي حصل عليه اليوم في
ظل ما بات يعرف بحلف الخصوم او حلف
الضروره يعني هل يبقى على سبيل المثال
نواب الحزب التقدمي الاشتراكي وهم ثمانيه
داعمين لجهد ازعور هل يبقى بعد الشخصيات
او هل تبقى بعد الشخصيات التي تسمى
تغييريه ايضا داعمه لجهاد ازعور اعتقد هنا
وحتى انهي كلامي وبعجاله ان الرقم الذي
حصل عليه جهاد ازعور هو رقم قابل للنزول
بينما الرقم الذي حصل عليه سليمان فرنجيه
رقم قابل
ولكن
هذه التساؤلات التي طرحتها سي توفيق شومان
هل يمكن لذلك ان يتحقق هل يبقى هذا
التوافق توافق اللحظه ربما او تقاطع
الضروره على اسم جهاد الزعور في المرحله
المقبله
وايضا العامل الخارجي سيد ميشيل الى اي
درجه
يمكن التعويل عليه من اجل احداث ملامح
لتوافق تؤدي لحوار
نعم صحيح ان هناك تقاطع عن حصل بين خصوم
ومتنافسين سياسيين على المرشح جهاد زعور
وانه ربما فريق سليمان فرنجيه متماسك اكثر
بنتيجه تاييد الثنائيه الشيعيه له الواضح
وهذا ما حصل ايضا في اليومين الاخيرين قبل
قبل جلسه اليوم من خلال محاوله استقطاب
بعض النواب لكن لا يعني ذلك ان ان رقم
جهاد الزهور بالضروره سينزل لان المصلحه
او الرؤيه المشتركه التي جعلت هؤلاء
الاصدقاء السياسيين يتقاطعون من اجل ايجاد
بديل لاسم بديل لسليمان افرنجيه ستبقى هي
نفسها اذا لم يتوفر خيار بديل اخر لان كان
كانت الذريعه التي يسوقها
تسوقها ثنائيه امل حزب الله انه لدينا
مرشحين افرنجيه ولكن القوه المناهضه له لا
تقدم مرشحا بديلا هذه القوه وترحت مرشحا
بديلا فطالما انها لم تجد من هو افضل من
جهاد ازعوده خود هذه المعركه سوف تبقى
متصله على هذا الاساس
نعم لا شك لا شك ان فرنسا بدلت في
مقاربتها السابقه التي كانت تقوم فقط على
مسايره او تقاطع المصالح بينها وبين حزب
الله واندفعت الى سياسه اخرى بعد الرفض
خاصه المسيحي الواضح لسليمان الفراجيه
وعدم قدرته على تخطي هذا الموضوع اضفي الى
ذلك مساله المراقبه الامريكيه اللصيقه
والحاثه للوضع اللبناني وهذا ما تبين في
الاتصال فيكتوريا نولد بالامس مع الرئيس
نبيه بري والقول له انه يجب ان تبقي
الجلسات مفتوحه حتى انتخاب الرئيس وموقف
اليوم الاستتباعي للخارجيه الامريكيه الذي
استنكر خروج افقاد يعني نصاب الدوره
الثانيه هذا العامل يجب النظر اليه بجديه
ستسهل
توافقات سيد توفيق شومان توافقات داخل
يعني هذا المرجل السياسي اللبناني امانه
ستزيده تعقيدا خاصه بانها عوامل ربما قد
لا تكون مراقبه من قبل كل الاطراف فرنسا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني صحيح بانه العامل الخارجي مؤثر ولكنه
لا يستطيع ان يفرد على اللبنانيين امرا
معينا هناك مجموعه من التجارب السابقه
حدثت مع الواقع السياسي اللبناني
وبالتحديد يعني بما له علاقه بالاستحقاق
الرئاسي عام 1988 على سبيل المثال كان
هناك توافق سوري سعودي امريكا على مخيل
الظاهر ولكن البيئات الطائفيه في الوسط
المسيحي او البيئات السياسيه في الوسط
المسيحي رفضت ذلك واسقطت مخيل الظاهر
الامر ذاته ايضا حدث بعد الاجتياح
الاسرائيلي للبنان في العام 1982 ايضا
كانت هناك بيئات سياسيه تنتمي الى طوائف
لبنانيه معينه استطاعت على سبيل المثال ان
تسقط كل المشروع الاسرائيلي ومن ضمن 17
ايار لكن 17 ايار مايو اتفاقيه بين لبنان
واسرائيل اظن بانه يعني هناك لابد من
طابقين من اجل الدخول الى التوافق
اللبناني الطابق الاول هو الطابق داخلي هو
الاساس والطابق وال الثاني هو الطابق
الخارجي هذا امر لا مفر منهم ولكن اعتقد
بانه يفترض ان يكون هناك نوع من الحكمه
عند المسؤولين السياسيين اللبنانيين ان
يتم انتاج رئيس او ان يتم انتخاب رئيس
عليه توافق خارجي او غير متعارض مع
السياسات العامه
للبنان والخارج وبالتالي ليس رئيس تحدي لا
في لبنان وبالخارج هذا هو المفترض ان
يختاروا ان تختاره السياسيه ولكن ان يفرض
الخارج شخصيه معينه هذا اعتقد بانه صعب
والمحلل السياسي وايضا من بيروت ميشيل ابو
نجم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه مقتله ثلاثه
اشخاص وجرح اخرين في قصف صاروخيا روسيا
على ميناء اوديسا واقل المتحدث باسم
الاداره العسكريه في اوديسا ان الهجوم
استهدف مجمعا تجاريا ودمر مستودعاته وتسبب
في حرائق على مساحه 400 متر مربع جهه
افاده السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
نوفاكاخوفكا بان قصفا اوكرانيا اسفر عن
اصابه شخص في المدينه
ومع استمرار القوات الاوكرانيه في هجومها
المضاد قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
صدت هجمات على ثلاث جبهات في دونيتس قوات
بيروجيه خلال الساعات الماضيه ونشرت
القوات المواليه لروسيا مقاطع فيديو او
مقطع فيديو قالت انه يوثق استهداف تحصينات
ومواقع للجيش الاوكراني بمسيارات انتحاريه
في مكان لم تحدده في دونيتسك
قالت القوات الجويه البريطانيه ان احدى
طائراتها في استونيا اعترضت بعد ظهر
الاربعاء طائره تابعه لسلاح الجو الروسي
كانت تحلق بالقرب من المجال الجوي لحلف
الناتو واتهمت القوات الجويه البريطانيه
على حسابها في تويتر الطائره الروسيه
بالاخفاق في الامتثال للمعايير الدوليه
شفاء المستشار الالماني
النقابه عن اول استراتيجيه للامن القومي
في تاريخ البلاد الحديث واضاف ان المهمه
المركزيه للدوله هي ضمان امن مواطنيها من
دون تنازلات واشارت الحكومه الالمانيه
خلال الكشف عن الاستراتيجيه ان العالم
يشهد تناميا في تعدد الاقطاب والتنافس
واضافت ناروسيا تشكل اكبر تهديدا لاوروبا
ولحلف شمال الاطلسي في المستقبل المنظور
كما اوضحت ان الصين تشكل ضغطا متزايدا على
الاستقرار الاقليمي
لفه حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اليوم سيكون
لنا حديث معمق وموسع حول اعلان المانيا عن
اول استراتيجيه للامن القومي في تاريخ
البلاد الحديث والتي صنفت روسيا كاكبر
تهديد لاوروبا
[موسيقى]
قالت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه انها نشرت
طائرات من طراز اف 22 رابتر في الشرق
الاوسط في ضوء السلوك غير الامن لطائرات
الروسيه واضافت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
ان نشره طائرات يبرهن على قدره الولايات
المتحده على اعاده تموضع قواتها في وقت
وجيز وان المقاتلات الامريكيه سوف تندمج
مع قوات التحالف الدولي ضد تنظيم الدوله
في الجو وعلى الارض مؤكده ان انتهاك
القوات الجويه الروسيه لاجراء منع النزاع
يزيد مخاطر تصعيد وسوء تقدير بحسب القياده
الوسطى الامريكيه
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن قائد القوات الجويه
الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط الجنرال الكسوس
غرينتش قوله ان الروسي يحلقون منذ مارس
الماضي بشكل غير مهني فوق نطاق الوجود
الامريكي في سوريا واضاف الجنرال في
تصريحات مكتوبه للجزيره ان الروس يقومون
بذلك بشكل دوري منذ عام 2019
ويقوضون الجهود الامريكيه
برفضهم الالتزام بالبروتوكولات المتفق
عليها وقلق قائد سلاح الجو الامريكي في
الشرق الاوسط ان الطيران الروسي في سوريا
يناور بشكل عدواني وهو يحمل على متنه
ذخيره حيه ما يمثل تصعيدا في سياق الاحداث
الدوليه الراهنه
انضموا الينا من واشنطن مراسلنا فادي
منصور فادي ما الذي يعنيه نشر طائرات من
طراز اف 22 رابتور في الشرق الاوسط في ضوء
ما تحدثت عنه القياده الوسطى الامريكيه
نعم القياده الوسطى الامريكيه في بيانها
وتصريحات قائد سلاح الجو الامريكيه في
الشرق الاوسط الجنرال
للجزيره تشير الى انزعاج امريكي كبير من
استمرار الجانب الروسي في انتهاك
الالتزامات المبرمه ما بين واشنطن وموسكو
وفق الروايه الامريكيه بطبيعه الحال
المتعلقه بالاجراءات التي جرت الاتفاق
عليها في الاجواء السوريه لمنع التصادم ما
بين سلاحي الجو الروسي الذي ينشط في سوريا
والامريكي الذي ايضا ينشط في سوريا خلال
الفتره الماضيه سمعنا كثيرا من الجنرال
جراند شكاوى من قيام الجانب الروسي
بالتحليق بشكل غير مهني بشكل ينافي
للاجراءات التي جرى الاتفاق عليها وفي
كثير من الاحيان بطائرات تحمل ذخيره حيه
وايضا فوق ما تصفه الولايات المتحده
بالاجواء التي تسيطر عليها في سوريا فيما
يشير الى تحليق الطيران الروسي فوق
القواعد التي تنتشر فيها القوات الامريكيه
وبالتالي هذه الخطوه هي محاوله لبعث رساله
واضحه للولايه لموسكو بان واشنطن قادره في
اي وقت تريده على نشر قوه قويه ليست فقط
قويه للغايه ولكن متطوره طائرات اف 22
هي من احدث طرز الطائرات في العالم هي من
الجيل الخامس تتسم بقدرتها العاليه على
الفرار وعدم التقاطها من قبل الرادارات
وايضا على توجيه ضربات في العمق لتحديدا
فيما يتعلق بالاشتباك مع اسلحه الجو
الاخرى ولكن ايضا يمكن تزويدها بصواريخ
قادره على ضرب اهداف ارضيه وبالتالي
الولايات المتحده تحاول ان تقول ان قواتها
في سوريا ليست معزوله تستطيع تحريك سرب
مثل السرب الرابع والتسعين والتي تقع
قاعدته في اللانجلي بالقرب من واشنطن في
ولايه فرجينيا الى مسافه طويله تصل الى
الشرق الاوسط بطبيعه الحال لكي تتمكن من
حمايه هذه القوات وهناك اشاره واضحه ايضا
في تصريحات قائد سلاح الجو الامريكي في
الشرق الاوسط عندما اشار الى ان هذه
الاجراءات التصعديه تاتي في سياق دولي
تهدد عمليا بمفاقمه الوضع وايضا سوء
التقدير في اشاره الى التوتر القائم حول
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى التوتر في البلقان وتصعيد جديد بين
كوسوفو وصربيا فقد اعلنت الحكومه الصربيه
اعتقال افراد من شرطه كوسوفو بعد دخولهم
الاراضي الصربيه مدججين بالسلاح حسب
تعبيرها واكد مسئول صربيا ان القوات
الصربيه لم تخترق الحدود بين البلدين
اثناء عمليه الاعتقال
وبينما دعت رئيسه كوسوفو المجتمع الدولي
الى مواجهه ما وصفته بمحاولات صربيا زعزعه
استقرار المنطقه قال رئيس وزراء كوسوفو ان
اختطاف الصربيه لثلاثه ضباط من شرطه
كوسوفو داخل اراضي بلادهم عدوان غايته
التصعيد وزعزعه الاستقرار حسب تعبيره وطلب
بالافراج الفوري عن من سماهم ضباط الشرطه
الثلاثه المختطفين
الى تركيا التي شهدت جوله جديده من
مفاوضات انضمام السويد الى النيتو حيث قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان بلاده
قد لا تلبي توقعات السويد المرشحه لحلف
الناتو خلال قمته الشهر المقبل واضاف انه
لا يمكن لتركيا التعامل مع عضويه السويد
في الحلف بايجابيه بينما يواصل الارهابيون
مظاهراتهم هناك على حد تعبيره مشيرا الى
ان التعديلات الدستوريه التي اجرتها
السويد لا تكفي لمعالجه مخاوف تركيا
وقالت رئاسه التركيه انه تم الاتفاق مع
السويد وفنلندا وحلف شمال الاطلسي على
مواصله العمل بشان خطوات انضمام السويد
للحلف من جهه قال كبير مفوضي الوفد
السويدي ان بلاده ليست ملاذا امنا للارهاب
او لحزب العمال الكردستاني مضيفا ان
مفاوضات السويد مع تركيا بشان عضويه نيتو
ستستمر واشار الى ان هدف الحكومه السويديه
ما زال ان تصبح السويد عضوا في النيتو
باسرع ما يمكن وكانت الاليه المشتركه
دائما المتعلقه بالضمام السويد الى الناتو
قد عقدت اليوم اجتماعها الرابع في انقره
من جهه جانبه قال الامين العام لحلف في
شمال الاطلس ان المحادثات بشان انضمام
السويد الى النيتو احرزت بعض التقدم واضاف
ان السويد اجرى تعديلات في دستورها وعززت
قوانين محاربه الارهاب وان الوقت قد حان
لتتفق الاطراف جميعا على تصديقي على
انضمامها للنيتو
بالرئيس اردوغان في اسطنبول قبل اسبوعين
تحدثنا عن عضويه السويد واتفقنا على دعوه
اللجنه المشتركه بين السويد وتركيا
وممثلين نيتو التي تجري المشاورات وتحدثت
الى رئيس هذه اللجنه قال ان الاجتماع جرى
في جو بناء وتم تحقيق تقدم وسنستمر في
العمل من اجل التصديق على عضويه السويد
بالسرعه الممكنه
من اسطنبول دكتور مسعود حقي جاشين عضو
مجلس الامن والسياسات الخارجيه التابعه
لرئاسه الجمهوريه التركيه وايضا من
السوكوند متريوس كرماء نامس كبير الباحثين
السابق في معهد الدفاع الوطني السويدي
مرحبا بكما دكتور مسعود حقي في اسطنبول
لماذا على السويد الا تتوقع بان
انقره ستغير موقفها حياه الانضمام السويد
في القمه المقبله
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام شكرا جزيلا
مساء الخير والسلام عليكم اذا
نامل ان الخطوات الجديديه والمهمه سوف
تؤخذ لانضمام السويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وخصوصا بالنسبه الى موضوع الارهابي في
السويد المرتبط بحزب العمال
الكردستاني اعتقد ان هناك
فهم بالنسبه الى الحلفاء هناك
قلق مرتبطه بتركيا تركيا تركيا ليست ضد
انضمام البلدان الى حلف شمال الاطلسي حتى
السويد ونتذكر ان تركيا اعطت الضوء الاخضر
لفنلندا كي تنضم الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
ولكن هناك مطالب
عربت عن تركيا بخصوص السويد ولا ينفع
الضغط على تركيا تركيا كانت واضحه وقالت
للسويد انه يجب ان لا تسمح بانشطتي حزب
العمال الكردستاني في السويد وهذا ما سلط
عليه الضوء الرئيس اردوغان في موقفه قال
الرئيس اردوغان انه لا يمكننا ان نقارب
هذا الموضوع بطريقه ايجابيه مع استمرار
ستوكه في موقفها بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
وبالنسبه الى هذه النقطه نحن لا نتحدث عن
سياسه ضد السويد ولكن هناك
نقطه مهمه للغايه يجب ان تؤخذ بعين
الاعتبار بالنسبه الى امن تركيا وهناك
ضروره لمكافحه الارهاب من قبل الدول
الاعضاء في حلف شمال الاطلسيه
وايضا نعرف ان هناك سوابق في هذا المجال
وموقف اسطنبول موقف انقره واضح وخصوصا
ايضا بعدما حصل في الهجوم الاخير في
اسطنبول
انقل هذه الافكار للسيده كار كمان
من ستوكهولم هل باستطاعه السويد ان تلبي
بواعث القلق هذه وان تهدئ من بواعث القلق
هذه وتلبي تطلعات تركيا
لملف الامن الذي تتحدث عنه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بحزب العمال الكردستاني
مساء الخير لكم
انا يمكنني كذلك ان اقرا
نصا طويلا كالزميل من
من تركيا ولكنني لن اقوم بذلك سوف اتحدث
اليكم بشكل مباشر لكي اقول ان السويد
اتخذت كل الخطوات المطلوبه بعد الاتفاق في
مدريد في العام الماضي والخطوه الاهم
والاخيره التي اتخذت كانت
التعديل في التشريعات السويديه المرتبطه
بموضوع مكافحه الارهاب ما جعل من المشاركه
في منظمات ارهابيه فعلا جرميا في السويد
وذلك من اجل اخذه مخاوف تركيا بين
الاعتبار وبالتالي ايضا هذا التشريع يمنع
عمليه تمويل هذه المنظمات اذا وفقا
للمسؤولي
السويديين ووفقا للحكومه السويديه لقد
قامت بالوفاء بكل الالتزامات التي اعربت
عنها في مدريد وبالتالي السؤال هو الان
وقد اصبحت الكره في ملعب تركيا ما الذي
سوف تقوم به تركيا من وجهه نظر اعتقد ان
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يقول في
تصريحاته انه يتعين على الجميع ان
يعرف ان لتركيا مخاوف محدده وهذه من بين
التكتيكات التي استخدمها الرئيس اردوغان
لتحقيق اهدافه هو يحاول ان
يراهن على هذه النقطه في مفاوضاتهم مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وخصوصا بشان
طائرات الاف 16 التي طلبتها تركيا لتحديث
الاسطول الجوي التركي ووفقا للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هذا الموضوع درس
واليوم
الممثل ممثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اشار الى هذه النقطه بالنسبه الى
موضوع انضمامي السويد الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي قال يجب على تركيا ان توافق وبعد
ذلك تفتح الطريق امام
تزويد تركيا بطائرات الاف سته عشر
كبير الباحثين السابق في معهد الدفاع
الوطني السويدي واشكر ايضا من اسطنبول
ضيفنا دكتور مسعود حقيق جاش ينضو مجلس
الامن والسياسات الخارجيه التابعه لرئاسه
الجمهوريه التركيه شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
عوده الى موضوع الاستراتيجيه الامنيه
الالمانيه الجديده حيث تسعى برلين الى
مواكبه المتغيرات العالميه على المستوى
العسكري والجيو السياسي بعد عقود من
تكبيرها باتفاقيات ما بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه فما ملامح تلك الاستراتيجيه
وابعادها صنفت الوثيقه الالمانيه المؤلفه
من نحو 80 صفحه روسيا بوصفها اكبر تهديدا
للسلام والصين باعتبارها شريكا ومنافسا
وخصما منهجيا ويشكل كلاهما تحديا امام
القوه الاقتصاديه الاولى في اوروبا وذلك
بسبب حرب على اوكرانيا اصبحت موسكو احد
اكبر الاخطار الامنيه على المنطقه
الاوروبيه الاطلسيه في المستقبل المنظور
وهو ما يستدعي اعاده تسليح المانيا بما
يناسب تلك التحولات اما بيجين
فتتهمها الوثيقه بتعريض الاستقرار
الاقليمي والامن العالمي لضغوط متزايده من
خلال محاولاتها اعاده تشكيل النظام الدولي
القائم
السياده الاقليميه وتجاهل حقوق الانسان
بشكل يتعارض مع المصالح والقيم الغربيه
لكن رغم ازديادي عناصر الخصومه والمنافسه
مع الصين تشدد وثيقه برلين على استمرار
العمل وفق مبدا الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي لا
يسعى الى قتل العلاقات معها تماما وانما
الى تقليل المخاطر كما تتضمن الاستراتيجيه
الالمانيه الامن السيبراني بما يتضمنه من
مكافحه للتجسس فضلا عن التهديدات المناخيه
ومكافحه الاحتباس الحراري وهو ملف يتبناه
بقوه حزب الخضر احد اضلاع الائتلاف
الحكومي اذا اعلان المانيا استراتيجيتها
للامن القومي سبقته خطوات كثيره منذ تسلم
الائتلاف الحكومي مهامه قبل عامين من ابرز
تلك الاجراءات
تغيير العقيده العسكريه للجيش الالماني
اثر بدء الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا حيث
ادخلت تغييرات على قوانين تمويل الجيش
تجهيزه وعلى نمط مهامه خارج الحدود خلافا
للسائد منذ انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وقد تعزز ذلك بتصويت البرلمان الالماني
البونجستاج في يونيو عام 2022 على تعديل
دستوري يسمح بتخصيص مئه مليار يورو لتزويد
الجيش بطائرات مقاتله جديده واسلحه متطوره
اخرى كما مرر البوندستاج قانونا يقضي برفع
الانفاق الدفاعي لالمانيا بشكل دائم فوق
اثنين في المئه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
وهو ما يؤهل البلاد قريبا لامتلاك اكبر
جيش تقليدي بين جميع اعضاء حلف الناتو
الاوروبيين للمزيد ينضم الينا من برلين
الدكتور بنجامين تاليس وهو كبير الباحثين
في المجلس الالماني للعلاقات الخارجيه
الخارجيه ومركز الامن الدولي بكليه هارتي
مرحبا بك دكتور بن جميل اذا ما هو النهج
الالماني الجديد في رؤيه
الامن القومي
ضمن هذه المقاربه التي طرحت في هذه الورقه
مساء الخير لكم من برلين ويسعدني ان اكون
معكم على شاشه الجزيره نعم ان
الاستراتيجيه الاولى الالمانيه للامن
القومي التي اعلن عنها تعزز مبدا الامن
المتكامل ان يكون الامن قويا
وصامدا
ومستداما ونتحدث عن تعزيزات امنيه خارجيه
والداخليه باضافه الى المعدات الامنيه
والامن المرتبط بالبيئه اذا هي مقاربه
شامله وواسعه مرتبطه بالامس في هذه
الوثيقه هل بامكان المانيا ان تحقق مثل
هذه الهديه الاهداف
ما الميزانيه المرصوده وضمن ما تمتلكه
ايضا لتحقيق هذه الاستراتيجيه
كلا ليس بحسب الميزانيه الحاليه وهذه من
بين المشكلات التي يمكن ان اتطرق اليها في
هذه الاستراتيجيه تعبر عن تطلعات وامال
ولكنها تبقى هكذا في غياب التمويل خصوصا
بالنسبه الى موضوع المعدات العسكريه
وذكرتم التعديل والقانون الذي مر على
مستوى البرلمان الالماني ولكن بالرغم من
ذلك لا تملك الحكومه الالمانيه ما يكفي من
اموال
لتنفيذي
ما ورد في هذه الوثيقه بنسبه الى المعدات
العسكريه وذكرت الوثيقه ان المانيا لديها
مسؤوليه محدده بالنسبه الى الامن الاوروبي
نظرا الى ثقلها السياسي والاقتصادي وايضا
التاريخي اذا هناك الجناح الشرقي
الذي يعاني من تهديدات الروسيه ولكن في
هذه الوثيقه ما من اشاره عمليه حول كيفيه
تنفيذ هذه الامور اين نكمل الثغرات دكتور
بن جميل برايك بالاضافه الى موضوع
النقص في التمويل او الميزانيه
الى الثغرات يمكننا ان نتحدث عن القدرات
العسكريه الالمانيه بالنسبه الى حاجه
الجيش الالماني الى معدات محدده وخصوصا
الدبابات
القتاليه والطائرات القتاليه التي
باستطاعتها ان تنفذ المهام بعيده المدى
التي قد يتطلب ذلك الوضع ان يقوم بتنفيذها
سلاح الجو الالماني اذا هناك ثغرات متعدده
على المستوى العسكري ايضا مرتبطه بالجانب
اللوجستي اضافه الى ذلك هناك ثغرات اخرى
من غير الواضح كيف لالمانيا ان تنفذ هذه
النقطه المرتبطه بالحفاظ على العلاقات
الجيده مع الصين ولكن في الوقت نفسه خفض
الاعتماد الكامل او الكبير على الصين
وبالتالي هناك افكار متناقضه في هذه
الوثيقه بالنسبه الى كيفيه التعامل مع
الصين ذكرت الصين على انها شريك ولكن في
الوقت نفسه منافس استراتيجيه ومن غير
الواضح بالنسبه الي وبالنسبه الى مراقبين
اخرين في برلين كيف لهذه الاستراتيجيه ان
تنفذ في حال نشب نزاع بالنسبه الى تايوان
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي الحليفه
الاهم لالمانيا طلبت من المانيا ان تصطفها
الى جانب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي هذه من بين الامور الغامضه في
ضمن ايضا سياق ما تحدثت عنه بان يعني هذه
الاستراتيجيه يعني هي تميز المانيا كونها
هي يعني لديها مثل هذا الالتزام والثقل
التاريخي بالنسبه لاوروبا الى اي درجه مثل
هذه الاستراتيجيه
يعني تستطيع فيها المانيا ان تكون ق اطره
لاوروبا ضمن استراتيجيه الامن الاوروبي
الاكثر توسعا
لا اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه تغير الكثير
بهذا الشان انها تتطلع الى قيام المانيا
بادوار اكثر واكبر ولكن في حقيقه الامر
وبالنظر الى الثغرات التي سبق واشرت اليها
لا اعتقد ان الامور سوف تتغير وهذا
بالنسبه الى العلاقه مع الحلفاء
حلفاء المانيا اذا هذا امر اساسي بالنسبه
الى الاستراتيجيه الالمانيه والمقاربه
الالمانيه للامن ولكن على المستوى العملي
لا تنفذ على سبيل المثال بولندا غير
مذكوره في هذه الوثيقه وهناك عمل كبير يجب
ان يتم وبالاضافه الى ذلك المملكه المتحده
غير مذكوره في وثيقه الاستراتيجيه وهي من
بين الحلفاء الاساسيين لالمانيا ولكن الم
لديها دور اساسي تؤديه ولكنها لم تجد
السبل او الطرق لتاديه هذا الدور لربما
لانها لا تؤدي من ضمن فريق بشكل جيد يجب
ان تنسج العلاقات الاقوى مع الحلفاء لكي
تعيد التفكير
بتضييعه قوتها ونفوذها في العالم القياده
الالمانيه وما من اتفاق بالنسبه الى هذه
المواضيع بين الائتلاف الحاكم في برلين
شكرا لك من برلين دكتور بنجامين تالس كبير
الباحثين في المجلس الالماني للعلاقات
الخارجيه ومركز الامن الدولي بكليته شكرا
لك
نقلت صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال عن مصادر ان
الاداره الامريكيه استانفت محادثات سريه
مع ايران في محاوله لوقف برنامج طهران
النووي والافراج عن المعتقلين الامريكيين
وبحسب مصادر صحفيه فان مسؤولين بالبيت
الابيض زاروا سلطنه عمان ثلاث مرات على
الاقل لاجراء مزيدا من الاتصالات غير
المباشره مع ايران كما نقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين سابقين في كوريا الجنوبيه ان
المناقشات مستمره بين طهران وواشنطن بشان
الافراج عن سبعه مليارات دولار من الاموال
الايرانيه المحتجزه في كوريا الجنوبيه
مقابل الافراج عن امريكيين محتجزين في
ايران وافقت صحيفه فان دوله قطر كانت
تتوسط ايضا في المناقشات بين طرفين بشان
الافراج عن السجناء الامريكيين في ايران
بهذا ننهي حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لكم على
المتابعه الى اللقاء بحول الله
[موسيقى]